relogement dans les outre-mer merci
madame la parole et à monsieur julien
dive la caisse ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre
dans ma région des hauts de france des
manifestants la loi travail ont décidé
de s'introduire dans une mairie afin de
perturber le conseil d'agglomération et
d'occuper la salle sans coopération
l'évacuation a été difficile avec des
dégradations du mobilier public
le vol d'une statue de marianne et des
insultes lancées à l'encontre des élus
de forces de sécurité
à paris les participants de nuit debout
ne respecte plus toujours leur limite
d'autorisation préfectorale pour quitter
la place de la république provoquant de
fréquents débordements lors de son
évacuation
on observe par ailleurs des violences
lors de manifestations comme à rennes
nantes lyon toulouse la semaine dernière
où policiers et manifestants furent
parfois gravement blessé ces incidents
inadmissibles
ni les valeurs de la république et
bafoue l'autorité de l'état si nous nous
devons d'éviter toute confusion entre
une minorité radicale porté sur l'action
violente et la majorité des manifestants
qui aspirent à un débat démocratique
vous conviendrez monsieur le premier
ministre que la situation du pays
apparaît de plus en plus hors de
contrôle
ce climat délétère pour chacun a campé
sur ses positions et a radicalisé ses
moyens d'action la plupart de ces
violences auraient pu être évitées si le
gouvernement avait vraiment pris la
mesure des événements qui se déroulent
partout en france les dispositifs de
sécurité actuelles ne sont de toute
évidence pas adaptés à ses nouvelles
manifestations citoyennes
le gouvernement ne semble pas avoir
compris que ces mouvements spontanés
issus des réseaux sociaux sont amenées à
se développer de plus en plus la société
civile exprime une nécessité de dialogue
et de contribution au débat que nous
pouvons que nous ne pouvons ignorer et
que nous devons intégrer à notre façon
d'envisager la politique d'aujourd'hui
comment anticipez-vous l'émergence en
france de ces nouvelles formes de
contestation
que proposez-vous pour assurer la
sécurité des participants
des riverains et des forces de l'ordre
qui encadraient les manifestations
comment comptez vous gérer l'état
d'urgence sans empêcher le débat
démocratique
bien si la parole est à monsieur bernard
cazenave ministre de l'intérieur oui
monsieur le monsieur le député dit vous
posez des questions de fond sur lesquels
je veux là aussi apporter des réponses
de 2 précise d'abord vous poser la
question de savoir quelle est la
compatibilité entre l'état d'urgence et
la liberté d'expression vous le savez le
conseil constitutionnel a eu dans le
cadre de l'état d'urgence comme le
conseil d'état à dire quel était le
droit et dans la décision du 16 février
2016 le conseil constitutionnel a très
clairement indiqué que l'état d'urgence
qui est un dispositif que la démocratie
mobilise la république pour protéger les
principes de liberté ne peut pas être
utilisée pour remettre en cause la
liberté d'expression et le conseil
d'état lorsqu'il a été saisi par des
particuliers pour juger de la pertinence
des mesures de l'état d'urgence a posé
les mêmes principes de droit par
conséquent lorsque certains
représentants de votre formation
politique ce n'est pas le sens de votre
propos je les bien notées indique que la
solution pour éviter les débordements et
d'interdire les manifestations
si nous mettions en oeuvre ce qu'ils
disent regard de ce que sont les
décisions du conseil constitutionnel
nous prendrions le risque d'être cassée
par le juge l'autorité de l'état s'en
trouvera est affaibli et les violences
dans les manipulent dans les
manifestations risquerait de sang
trouvées décuplée donc le premier point
sur lequel je voudrais insister c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de possibilité
d'affirmer l'autorité de l'état
là où il n'y a pas la volonté de
respecter rigoureusement les principes
de droit deuxième point il faut être
intraitable avec les casseurs et pour ce
qui concerne la manifestation dans la
mairie d'amiens
la mère a eu un très grand sang froid le
député geste également les forces de
l'ordre ont été immédiatement mobilisées
elles ont procédé à l'évacuation des
lieux et les casseurs ont été
interpellés et ils seront jugés
c'est aussi ça l'état de droit troisième
point sur lequel je voudrais insister
c'est sur la nécessité dans un contexte
de tension d'être dans la responsabilité
est d'éviter absolument d'avoir des
discours qui crée des tensions pour
qu'après les tensions il y ait des
incidents et que derrière les incidents
il y ait des blessés éventuellement
davantage je ne le veux pas c'est la
raison pour laquelle